我真的是很討厭戀
上同時出現又有又乾乾
而且是略空的乾
略度越有
她不知道我就想真的
零一今天跟小麥有
那一乾或不輸入
其實這個時候
臉上並不是水油不平衡
而是我們的平常受損了
所以這個時候單純的空油
或者是不水
都起不到任何的作用
反而會讓臉
覺得願意滅了一個乾
這個就有
這個時候你就可以按照
我今天分享這個方法來做
外有那乾的感覺
真的是能環節的很快
它先說一個冷靜
很多萬有那乾
其實都是因為洗臉不當早冷的
要我們就是用那種
大碗造季節
要我們就是切碗裝蟲
還要二次清潔
導致過度清潔了
要我們就是把臉
幫助盤子一樣來挖
把臉挖的通口
正確的方法
應該是用這種洗油
不洗致的節的來洗
這個我分享的
他們全部都是
APPG的飆火腿
非常非常溫和
但是又可以把臉洗乾子
四個時候水溫
不要太高
然後手在臉上清清的
按壓就可以了
不要來回地去做
這兩次洗臉
就是又乾淨
但是又不會傷害的病
你知道
跟在我
從洗乾淨之後
就可以用一個
濾露精華
跟土量三棒來打底
給我的皮膚做一個
三層的補水
和微溫球
再點一個這種
又清漲
但是修過濾有非常好
土墨裡面的
那蔥墨是因為我
這個一個納分漲
我它很適合我們有命比
就是外有那一乾
它其實就是有命比
外有那一乾的飽門
或服補一樣
注意三個重點
修護品
這樣蒸層補水
以及改善活活
這一次
它只是這三點
全部都能活到
它是這種
非常清淨的
就有一個意思
而此
還是無油配方
所以非常適合我們有命比
負責的人
雖然是那種
冰冰涼涼的
它透氣很透氣
就是我感覺現在
我補到的一方
就覺得它
在大口的喝水
很舒服
不用擔心說
用這個土墨
是因為我會讓我們弄動
現在就是感覺像
造了一層水
我在臉上
原本不斷的皮膚
灌水一天去
它裡面會有力
丟丟的酸
但是又了
很多的修護層分來包裹
目的是為了
幫我們打開皮膚的通道
讓後續的
會不會更好的
被我們的皮膚吃起來
所以不用擔心
會刺激
平時經常吃完
命度臉的剪的
也可以常被一品
這個在家裡面
既然光電
可以用看一些
快速修護
我們副食道
是我分鐘
之後就可以去洗掉的話
其實完了之後
我絕對我的這個皮膚
真的是
基於軟
QQ彈彈的
接下來就是
我們的後續護膚軟
洗完臉之後
我們一定要抓緊
時間難附服
我發現有很多節目
洗完早
洗完臉的時候
先是
慢用的吹一頭放
然後再塗個身體
爐帶來護膚
如果有這個洗完的話
一定要改
尤其是平常受損的節目
它會加上水分
蒸發到
我們基地更乾脆的水
後續護膚清量水的清涉
洗休護你槍的
不要用那種很有潤的
哪怕它的休護你再好
在我們有血的臉上
也很容易溫重一點對我來
果分身有綠州精華
來進行全臉搭
它是一款非常厲害的
修護水精華
堅持用的話
可以給我們的皮膚進行
深度的無血
也可以把我的平髒
兩碼和厚食
這款聽話
我覺得這就是外有
那一乾寶貝的
鮮水精華
精華是受了差不多了
我們再來
從一個都底白
三層都底
給你們看一下
看了這種風感
不是這種特點
就有的清爽特點水
因為外有那一乾七身品
上上其實有很多
我們讓我一點看見的香口
因為裡面的水分
就會從小口
慢慢有時
那都底
就相當於是給我們的皮膚
我們外在加外一層金鐘照
把一樣程度和水分
都老老的服風飲在我們皮膚裡
你只要用的話
外有那一乾
就會感上很多
今天的護膚跟練士品
就到這裡囉
我們趕著一下
現在的皮膚就是
感覺又是水
但是又不有你
我之前的在護群面分享過
好幾個姐妹
大快說效果很好
最短的
一個月除內
他們的這種型號
就感受了很多
所以外有那乾淨姐妹
一定要試試看